I knew that you had co-written
bridesmaids with Kristen Wiig yeah what
I didn't know is that you were pregnant
very pregnant during the shooting of the
movie I was and you had to be there
every day as the co-author of the script
you had to be there and you had to be on
set and it was a pretty drag you're
there 17 hours a day right and I was
seven months pregnant when we started
shooting and it's a 10-week shoot so you
go I went through the full nine just by
the end it was I was just a I was a huge
ball mm-hmm and I couldn't sit in the
set chairs anymore and they would just
roll me they would roll me I would roll
around on the floor to do my writing and
then they would roll me into the golf
cart to go eat and then roll back into
the cart back to just roll around I
rolled I was just rolled we have a
picture of you on set of bridesmaid
that's just fantastic yeah it takes me
right back and I have the glow yeah I
get a great lie of pregnancy hello that
is a huge lot people who have that I
know right don't trust you yeah now you
have the glow if a woman has the glow
yeah something's wrong
bridesmaids what's interesting is it was
you part of what inspired the script was
your experience of being a bridesmaid
many many many times over isn't it yes I
was many times it was a period of my
life for I have a really big family and
have a lot of cousins and a lot of my
friends all were getting married a
period of like two to three years and I
was um I was perpetually a bridesmaid
like all the time all the time there
were times when I had two going at once
I was like double-fisting is not the
word
no no it's absolutely the wrong word
you came up with the worst yeah not that
work no no no so you were doing it you
were just constantly yes I was
constantly all the time and I I lived in
a studio apartment in Burbank and I was
like doing shows The Groundlings and my
apartment was a had like this brown and
black shag carpeting and it was humble
right we've all had that phase I loved
out here when I first left out here in
LA I had a $380 a month apartment oh
yeah looked out onto an alley and I had
a cardboard cutout that someone gave me
of a Miss America and I put it in the
window so it looked like I had a
girlfriend and people just thought why
is his girlfriend just always standing
at the window holding a bouquet but yeah
we all had that phase yeah how bad was
your place was I was by dumb you know
had a window I didn't have air
conditioning or heating so I tried to
put one of those window air conditioner
units in and then it would have a you
know it doesn't cover the whole windows
there's a nice hole that I just shoved
some cardboard in as a screen and I
would go to all these fancy you know
Bridal you know bridesmaid things and I
won point my door swelled shut so I had
to go in and out of my apartment through
the hole next to my air conditioner
these dresses in a bridal dress I'm good
and the going in is like your nose
you're going you're just diving yeah
going into the apartment so um I was in
these dresses and going out of this hole
in my apartment and then I had the same
car that Christmas character drove and
the movie was like an old Miss Vichy
Mirage that was based on your car it was
based on my car was given to me by my
grandpa
grandfather passed away in hurt the car
so that we didn't give it to you he
passed away and you get I got the car
yeah I had three of my grandparents cars
after that was just that's what happened
hey everybody felt sorry for me they
were just getting stuff anyhow all this
will be yours
someday this Mitsubishi Mirage yours I
would pull up these fancy country clubs
in this car and like I had both of you
review mirrors hanging up and I tried to
duct tape one of them on and I I was
thought maybe I should write this down
cuz I don't know what else to do about
how I feel yeah but it's good you turned
it into one of the big hit movies of all
time that's that's great that you have
that negative experience and turned it
into something right yes
you